the iberian peninsula is home to the
lands of five countries
andorra and france in the north portugal
in the west with spain dominating the
rest
well most of the rest since country
number five which sits in this tiny area
in the south
is the united kingdom this territory is
called gibraltar and despite numerous
wars between the united kingdom and
spain britain still holds the territory
which raises the obvious question why
why does britain own gibraltar
so the first part of this question is
how did britain get a hold of gibraltar
in the first place
well the answer to that is simple in the
year 1700 the king of spain
died now normally a king dying wouldn't
be a problem but this king charles ii
didn't have any kids which of course
meant succession crisis
charles chose philippe of the house of
bourbon and grandson of louis xiv for
france to succeed him
this upset mostly everyone since it
played spain and its gargantuan empire
firmly in the french sphere of influence
and so of course
war everyone united against spain and
france and in 1704
english and dutch soldiers landed in
gibraltar and seized it to keep the
mouth of the mediterranean open
in 1713 in return for britain leaving
the war immediately spain opted to see
gibraltar to them forever
gibraltar's original population had
largely fled during the war and it was
stationed by british troops and from
then on acted as an important naval base
whose population grew thereafter
so britain now owned gibraltar but what
stopped spain from regaining it
it was a tiny stretch of land attached
to the spanish mainland so surely it
would have been simple to walk in and
take it
well turns out no it wasn't long until
spain and britain were back at war again
and despite laying siege to gibraltar a
further two times over the next 75 years
it always held out the largest siege
came during the american war for
independence when britain's attention
was focused on those rascals
spain with the help of the french laid
siege to gibraltar for four years hoping
to starve the people out
however the british were able to
resupply gibraltar due to the size of
their navy in spain's issues maintaining
its own
as you'll know britain lost the war as a
whole and so when both sides sat down to
negotiate why didn't spain use the
opportunity
to regain gibraltar one britain hadn't
been conquered or crushed and could
still fight meaning spain couldn't get
everything it wanted and two
it had more important land to regain
notably florida and also menorca both of
which it got
when all of that was over in 1783 spain
never made another military attempt to
retake the rock
so that's it all settled then right well
no the spanish government always
maintained a claim to gibraltar much of
which was down to its geographic
positioning at the mouth of the
mediterranean and also because its
continued loss was seen as a blight on
spain's national honour for the next
century and a half though very little
change with respect to gibraltar
that was until 1936 when the spanish
civil war broke out
the border was closed mostly because of
there being too many refugees trying to
flee spain and britain further built up
gibraltar's defenses this caused
disputes with spanish leadership since
previously there had been an agreed
neutral zone between the two areas
however spain wasn't looking and so
britain quickly built up an airfield
there which became useful when world war
ii broke out
now spain's new leader francisco franco
was clear that he wanted gibraltar back
however when he was offered the chance
to get it back by joining the axis in
world war ii with germany he declined
franco said no because the positives
didn't outweigh the negatives and also
his country was in ruins
in the post-war world there was a big
drive towards decolonization and
gibraltar was firmly in the crosshairs
of this movement
a referendum was held in gibralta to
determine whether the people wished to
be a part of spain or remain in overseas
territory of the united kingdom
and the results were extremely close
with over 99
of people opting to remain under the
control of the united kingdom
when franco caught a mild case of death
and his regime came to an end relations
between britain and spain improved and
after a series of negotiations the
border reopened
and despite the continuing dispute over
the status of gibraltar there would be
no further changes in its status and to
this day it remains a british overseas
territory
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons
james bisonette kelly money maker marvin
cassell moe rob waterhouse james
castaneda jerry lamdin gustav swan
jordan longley marcus asner charles the
first
rasheed ali coppertone maggie paxkowski
lexi schwinn miss is it
matthew shipley robert wetzel spinning
three plates spencer lightfoot
corso wolfe anthony beckett and winston
k wood